what is happening what will continue to
happen is that activists will bypass the
voting box and go straight to corporate
boardrooms it's this little thing called
ESG right environmental social
governance and it is simply a way for
the government for activists and and
some of those and within the government
who wants it you can't get it passed in
Congress so you bypass the voting box
and you go straight into the corporate
boardrooms and that and now we see these
um uh uh these uh business Elites like
Black Rock State Street Vanguard and
other and Coca-Cola and other companies
that are using their leverage to force
upon the American people different uh
different American values right and so
you see that going on and on and on
again so now we're approaching the time
when the federal government will not be
so um you know
big government and and trying to impede
upon your uh personal rights or even
trying to usurp the the state government
they would just bypass all of that and
and use these large corporations and
that is what they're doing under ESG
they also have a thing called impact
investment which is Big buzzword 21st
Century Investments so they get
corporations that go to the board they
basically get the board to think a
certain way and then that's where they
put their money whether it's through
charity or whatever into
you know events that they want to see
happen and or people that they think
will spread the message that they want
them to spread YouTubers things like
that absolutely well yeah well I mean
like like for example BlackRock State
Street uh Vanguard uh the three of those
asset managers they manage over 22
trillion dollars right and that is
larger than uh the United than America's
GDP so they manage more money than than
the wealthiest com uh country America
right and so that's a tremendous amount
of influence so when you look at just
these three
um asset managers alone they own 21 of
Exxon stocks and they leverage all of
that buying power to go in to kick off
three of their board members on exons
and replace them with three activist
board members right and and then you and
once they take over the largest of all
of the uh oil and gas companies now they
just use them as posters children as
they go to Chevron and mobile and others
and say if you don't do what we tell you
to do when it comes to stop drilling or
to adopt more or to try to transition
faster away from oil and into renewable
energy then we're going to do to your
company what we just did to the largest
uh company Exxon that's exactly what
they did and so they are literally not
only destroying the fiduciary
responsibility between and um the the
manager who manages the uh the
individual investors money so they're
messing up that relationship because if
you're managing my money your only focus
should be on maximizing my shareholders
wealth but if you're no longer focused
on maximizing my shareholders wealth but
now pushing a particular narrative now
you're changing traditional American
values and you're bypassing the voting
box to do it that's my concern with
doctors too because it used to be a
doctor to Patient it was like the
investor to the investor manager and
that was all they cared about was the
health of the patient now you've got I
don't know if BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard are on the boards of of
hospitals as well of uh insurance
agencies I wouldn't be surprised to find
out yes they are and so is it confirmed
three scope three is something that you
find in um in Chevron for example and so
what scope 3 is which is what these
activists are pushing it forces private
companies to become the Big Brother of
every other company in their supply
chain right so if you're Chevron you
should you should just be focused on
finding Investments to drill more oil
especially in a time that we find
ourselves right now but instead Scopes 3
says not only do you need to be
um green new energy compliant but that
insurance company that's selling you
insurance to protect your workers you
need to now play Big Brother to them and
make sure that they too are moving
towards doing everything they need to do
to be clean you're absolutely right on
the money and I would even say it goes
even bigger than private corporations it
happens to other countries like Sri
Lanka Sri Lanka of course we're going
along with the ESG score implementing
the ESG policies the world economic
Forum was like they're doing great and
amazing they're going to be the biggest
and brightest stars in the developing
world and what happened to Sri Lanka
they were deliberately destroyed by the
policies that they were extorted and
manipulated to implement that that
pushed diversity you know all these
issues diversity wokeness uh gender
equality all of that and then what
happened when they put in all the green
policies and all the policies that of
course it wrecked and utterly destroyed
their country and this wasn't an
accident this was done deliberately and
now the same policies that were tested
in Sri Lanka that were tested on the
corporations are being implemented
globally and are being introduced here
in the United States and we'll topple
the Western World from what I'm seeing
it wasn't a mistake no everything we're
seeing in Sri Lanka with the food riots
in the in the gas shortages and all that
that's the intended sequence they they
outright are saying it they're telling
Farmers not to farm they're saying oh
the farming is bad for the environment
so don't do it even though we're facing
a food shortage because of the war
they're saying they want to shut down
fossil fuels what do you think happens
take a look at Sri Lanka if that's the
country you want to live in by all means
keep on moving forward with these policy
plans but I'll tell you it's not the
conservatives the Libertarians and the
post-liberals who are going to be
dealing with it because these people are
getting out of cities it's going to be
the urban liberal who is oblivious
waking up one day and being like why are
there Marauders running through the
streets stealing everything why is there
no food and what do I do people in the
countryside aren't impervious because
the what happens is corporations will
try to sue the American people the
trans-pacific partnership with setting
it up so that corporations could sue the
American government if we weren't if we
were discriminating was the language
against their Oil Company whether we
weren't following ESG standards as
Citizens or we weren't buying their oil
and then the taxpayer has to pay for
that and the government will find Joey
baloney out in the middle on nowhere in
the woods and charge him taxes for some
corporation's agenda in Malaysia and how
do you escape from that other than
blatantly breaking the law citizen of
the world
like you're now a citizen of the world
right so so we are now responsible for
what happens in in another country I
mean when you think about these 87 000
new IRS agents who may or may not be
armed
um you know this is the world in which
we're about to wake up in and I agree
with you wholeheartedly this is not this
is very intentional none of this feels
organic right that it just happened upon
us in two short years I mean this has
this feels very intentional this has
been coming and building up for a very
long time some people say be before even
the UN 2030 Vision even before that
there was other visions and other
projects that were pushing forward the
same end goal but just back to the Sri
Lanka point because I think it's an
important one Sri Lanka had a 98 plus
ESG score right and and they did
everything when it came to any energy
policy domestic policy hiring policies
governmental policies they they follow
they followed and obeyed because they
were for the poorest country that
literally were extorted at the barrel of
a gun just like we saw with economic
Hitman uh with that amazing book that
detailed the Decades of U.S actions uh
against the developing World confessions
of an economic event sorry there uh
great book detailed how they were doing
this now they're doing this under a new
uh disguise under a new woke term it's
called ESG as you were bringing up and
it's not just the acquisition and the
Takeover of Corporations it's the
Takeover of countries they beta tested
Sri Lanka now they're going to be
testing it on the rest of the world what
happens is basically the Chinese
Communist party for the West it is and
when when you're in when you're in China
you'll start a business at a certain
point you need an office for the Chinese
Communist party in your business that's
what we were told by some Microsoft
that's true it's true so in the United
States what they're doing is ESG as the
exact same thing it is the ideological
component that all businesses must
adhere to giving some unified Authority
control over your business this and what
you're allowed to say or do did you conf
you've confirmed that BlackRock State
Street Vanguard they buy 18 to 22
percent of a public company and they
have a lot if not they have so many
publicly traded companies they have like
18 do they then put three board members
on their board is that like every time
I'm not sure about every time but that
is uh exactly what they did with Exxon
uh so again
Black Rock State Street Vanguard now
there are hundreds if not thousands of
these asset managers these are just the
top three and they manage over 22
trillion dollars of assets around the
world right and again that's larger than
the entire GDP of America so that so I
say that to say these people own a term
I mean they have a tremendous amount of
power and clout and leverage and
specifically to Exxon Mobil they own the
three of them 21 of uh of Exxon shares
and so what they did is that they worked
alongside this very small activist
manager I think it's called engine
number one and who had no clout to do
anything but engine number one put up
these three uh activists board members
and and BlackRock State Street Vanguard
they decided to come alongside engine
number one and to use their leverage and
their proxy votes to vote in those three
three board members right so they kicked
out three added three and Exxon Mobil
has gone woke you want to read can you
read can you read that one again okay
but this might be one it might be a
challenge where uh the whole thing the
whole thing the whole Blackness blurry
for me all right let me read it let me
read it okay BlackRock Inc is an
American multinational investment
company based in New York City founded
in 1988 initially as a risk management
and fixed income institutional asset
manager BlackRock is the world's largest
asset manager with U.S 10 trillion
dollars and assets under management as
of January 2022 BlackRock operates
globally with 70 offices in 30 countries
and clients in 100 countries BlackRock
has sought to position itself as an
industry leader in environmental social
and corporate governance ESG the company
has faced criticism for worsening
climate change its close ties to the
Federal Reserve System during the kova
19 pandemic anti-competitive behavior
and its unprecedented investments in
China and you know what I'll just add as
the cherry on top BlackRock just sounds
like the name of a villainous
organization from a mission impossible
movie I have my BlackRock right here
it's called obsidian and I believe
that's where they got the name is from
the city in the Looking Glass no there's
a lot of occult symbology when it comes
to Blackrock Black Cube which is also an
Israeli intelligence private Contracting
agency there's also religious aspects
here uh you know spiritual aspects like
Mecca it's a big black cat exactly so
there's there's a lot more reference to
this than than a lot of people realize
um black stone also this is all about
this black rock I don't know if it's
volcanic glass or what they're talking
what's Mecca what's the it's called the
Kaaba what's it made out of uh I don't
actually know but it's been there for a
while it's actually pretty it's it's
it's it's it's it's not the uh you're
talking about Mecca it's the thing
inside of it correct right right yeah
the other thing is not actually it's
commonly misconstrued as that's the
outer thing but it's actually just a
small thing that's been inside of Mecca
for thousands of years pre-islam if I'm
correct I heard it was like a meteorite
or something yeah now we're talking yes
um regarding anti-competitive behavior
for BlackRock I've read that BlackRock
State Street in Vanguard own each other
and it's just a slightly shares of each
other now yeah I would if anyone in the
chat can source that data for me and
send it to me on Twitter mines I'd love
to have another look at it this is like
10 years ago six years ago when I was
invested who owns these companies I want
to find the names of the guys but it
just turns out it's other corporations
and they well he's the CEO Larry Fink
founder the founder but who owns it I
don't know the CEO doesn't even have to
have a percent aliens and when you ask
people well what is ESG no one really
knows what ESG is I mean it is he is
it's a it's a huge dichotomy between
what they say it is and how it's gonna
revolutionize capitalism and then
there's reality of what's actually going
on right and it gives more and more
Insidious as you go in when you look at
the credit rating agencies I mean
they're making money hand over fist
BlackRock alone uh they charge uh five
times the fees for their ESG aware
awareness funds versus other funds that
are just you know just basic with all
kinds of companies in there but then
when you look at these ESG aware
companies that are when you look at
these ESG funds and you look at the
companies that are that are on the
inside of them BlackRock again one of
the largest ESG awareness funds uh 90 of
those companies and those awareness
funds are also in the S P 500 right so
what's the difference right but you're
charging five times the fee I want to
tell you why West Virginia is best
Virginia and why it is one of the best
states in blackrocks Wikipedia it is a
West Virginia Section Riley Moore the
state treasurer of West Virginia said in
June 2022 that BlackRock and five other
financial institutions would no longer
be allowed to do business with the state
of West Virginia because of their
advocacy against the fossil fuel
industry Moore said at a time when
energy demand is skyrocketing and
consumers are bearing the brunt of
General generationally High inflation it
makes absolutely no sense for financial
institutions to cut off Capital and
financing to these legal profitable
Industries simply because they don't
align with their radical social and
political agendas so good on you West
Virginia and I don't want to this is
when I was earlier talking about the
states revolting against the corrupt
government that's trying to censor them
it's more about the the corporations
that we should be focused on exactly
because again they are doing what would
never get passed in Congress so they are
by if you and I or if America wants to
change our values to where we just want
to Dish ditch uh fossil fuel and and you
know
who cares if the economy crashes let's
just all move down the path of
Renewables then we should be able to go
into a voting booth and we should just
vote in all leftists right who who say
that they just want to destroy America
energy if we want to say listen parents
do not control our children we want the
government to be able to control our
children if we want to start saying
listen it's all about social justice you
don't have to earn your your your title
meritocracy is out the window we should
be able as Americans to go into a voting
booth and vote those values into our
country but instead but that would never
pass because you'll never get the
majority of Americans to say yeah we
just want to upend everything so what
they're doing is they're bypassing you
and I as voters to decide what kind of
country we want to live in and they're
going to these corporate board Elites
and they are now using their leverage
all of their money to go into these
corporations and say if either you align
with what we're saying about
environmental that's climate change the
S is
um social
which is which is wokeness which is CRT
transgenderism with your children
transitioning your children and then the
governess ESG the governess it is
actually I I liken it to the glue that's
bringing all of it together right the E
the S and the G and so they're going to
these corporations and they're saying
either you align with what we say uh you
need to have X number of women X number
of black people X number it doesn't
matter if they earned it doesn't matter
if they if they deserve it you just put
them on your in in leadership because we
say it that is what they're doing and
they're saying it to the boards of the
companies and is it just like if you're
not going to go down so then they'll buy
off like certain members of the board
and be like now that we have a majority
of the board paid off you better do what
we say or we're gonna [ __ ] kick you off
the board kind of thing and it's not
just that I mean like that's one of the
things that they did I mean like as an
example that's what they did to Exxon
they replaced three of the board members
of Exxon and they put in three very
liberal uh activists climate change
activists as board members on axon right
so that was one of them coming in and
and and kind of taking over the board
but another thing that these companies
get to do again they manage a tremendous
amount of of
um of assets and so one of the things
they can do is just underweight how much
of your assets they're gonna they're
going to put their money in right
um and so and if you're a publicly held
company and people are selling off your
stocks that's not a good thing you want
people to be buying your stocks right A
lot of these CEOs they're their bonuses
their their compensation is tied to
their stock value so they can so instead
of taking over your board they can
simply underweight you because you're
not aligning with their principles they
pretty much they pretty much in work
like the mafia they come to you and
they're like you're going to do what we
say or we're going to steal money from
you and beat you down and destroy your
livelihood and then a lot of these
companies comply because they want a
good score they want to comply with
everything that they're doing but but I
think you're also wronging by just
calling them corporations they're not
just private corporations they are
entities that are working with the US
Federal Reserve printing money out of
thin air funneling it into Wall Street
with no accountability with no track
record with no transparency at all and
now when you have the coffers of the
Federal Reserve at your beck and call
you could do whatever you want you could
say hey we're going to invest money here
we're going to put money here we're
going to give this company here this
Corporation here all this money you want
some of it you got to go along get on
your knees and worship the altar of our
uh you know a rule that we're going to
be of course pushing on everyone and
it's even Beyond just even BlackRock
California mandated increased diversity
on their corporate boards that was a law
they had to comply so this was going
along with their policies that are being
implemented not through just economic
Force but also government Force as we're
seeing the same people responsible for a
lot of these policies coalesce and
Implement them in all aspects of life
you're right that calling Corporation is
not accurate they need new names for
these multi these I don't know megacorps
but then the word Corp is in there I'd
rather just focus call them something
unique when they've become I don't know
so prolific cabals cabals that's a good
way to put it legal cabals you said that
they underweight a corporation how does
that work if the BlackRock were to have
what are they they own 20 of the company
so how would they do that what would
that be well just for example like I
said they have 22 just those top three
22 trillion dollars right and then they
get to decide how much of their money of
your your money because it's really your
money it's not their money you invest in
one of their funds right and so they're
supposed to have this fiduciary
responsibility where it's all about
maximizing your profitability and so
they take your money so I save their
money but it's not really their money
it's your they manage roughly 22
trillion dollars and so they can decide
where they want to put that money and
that's stakeholder capitalism
stakeholder Now define a stakeholder
right you're here in America and you're
you know busting you're hot my
grandfather he was a janitor I mean I
mean it was just you know and so he
could take his money and try to invest
and he wants to retire but instead of
investing along his values his
principles and investing for the purpose
of maximizing his few dollars so that
one day maybe he can retire send his
kids off to college they take that money
and they say well hey my stakeholder is
not you the shareholder older right my
stakeholder is I don't know climate
change and some remote part of Africa
right building roads or schools or
social justice and some you know some I
don't know in the Amazon somewhere so
it's very nebulous it's very um there's
a tremendous amount of ambiguity the SEC
has now gotten involved because there's
a lot of green washing where you have
people who are just saying they're green
or that they're ESG compliant just
because in essence is I I liken it to
designer label right ESG is nothing more
than a designer label and you want to
have that Designer label because now you
can charge more fees you look Chic
people want to invite you to the
Christmas party and because it's because
it's there's nothing good that's coming
out from this so how did we end up with
Dr Oz instead of you
well Dr Oz I mean he doesn't seem to
know anything about this he doesn't talk
about it it seems very generic you were
running you seem to be extremely
knowledgeable at all of these issues
internationally and domestically and and
and the people of uh Pennsylvania that's
the choice they get well let me just say
um again the people of Pennsylvania are
some of the best people I I mean again
13 months 1500 miles every single week
um the overwhelming majority of the
rooms I walk in I was the only black
person in the room and yet I felt like I
was their sister I felt like we were in
um that we had a meeting of the minds
and we were trying to fight and win our
country back I absolutely love the
people of Pennsylvania my heart grieve
you know just because I believe they
deserve good leadership I believe they
deserve people who were actually not not
just Pennsylvania but all of America my
heart Grieves for us we are living in
very serious time times and we have some
very unserious quote-unquote leaders
right now right and everybody seemed to
be lining their own pocket when you look
at Nancy Pelosi and her husband Paul
Pelosi what it seems what appears to be
some insider trading going on who knows
right and you see that time and time
again you see all this money going over
to Ukraine and no one can tell you where
the money is going but hey let's trust
them although Ernst young ranks Ukraine
in the top five most corrupt countries
in the world right but hey let's just
send over another you know 12 billion
dollars and if you don't do it you must
be a Russian sympathizer right you can't
have any honest dialogue about some very
serious things that are going on right
now and that is the reason why I ran I
am the most unlikely candidate just to
give some perspective I ran against you
know the you know my two main primary
opponents they spent when you look at
what they spent and the money from the
packs they spent 60 million dollars on a
primary race right I spent less than two
million dollars and all of it came from
the people but this is what you get by
13 months 1500 miles knocking on every
door I have no regrets I left it all out
there on the on on the road now the
people have chosen in large part because
Sean Hannity is a jackass can I say that
yes
amen hallelujah
the people were manipulated we were
going to win Sean Hannity is a jackass
but we already know that I don't think
that's a cuss word I was asking Jesus
about that on the way up here
I mean it's a donkey right it's another
way of saying donkey but he is I know um
but nonetheless uh we're now in a race I
am not on the ballot
um I am I will be walking in voting
Republican all the way down because God
knows fetterman is a hot mess and I
would never vote for him
um and I would encourage pennsylvanians
to do the same to walk in and not vote
for fettermen I would actually even say
Hannity is a status stooge and I
definitely agree with your sentiments
he's a puppet absolutely remember puppet
of the intelligence but I really so for
seven different times he never once
asked me any of those riveting questions
and that he wanted to ask in the last
five days and what you're saying about
the ESG score is the nail in the head
it's one of the most important issues
that no one else wants to really talk
about most important and you covered it
very very well which which again a lot
of people don't do that and a lot of
people are afraid to talk about these
issues so I commend you for having the
courage for doing so and and speaking
about these issues so boldly but I just
wanted to ask you specifically what in
the world do you think Donald Trump was
thinking endorsing Oz over you what was
going through he said what's going on
here before you answer now y'all know I
gotta go back to Pennsylvania right so
don't get me in trouble with the people
I look forward to
um assuming we ever get the opportunity
sitting down with uh with former
president Trump I just saying to him now
when you made the terrible mistake of
endorsing Dr Oz Over Kathy Barnett did
you uh did you do it on purpose or were
you aware that it was a tremendous
mistake and you did it anyway
well Oz is famous and I love Fame like
what's he I don't know he's drawn to the
light everyone agreed
to agree steak you should not have
endorsed Oz everyone everyone's like at
least that's what I was told what would
you say to that
what did it well I was going to ask what
Hannity what did he do that in the last
he lied about you he lied really oh he
dragged me he dragged to your face no
he's a punk he of course he wasn't right
and I went on Twitter and I said well
since you have all of these riveting
questions I am
um gonna you know I'm gonna hold Monday
9 p.m uh come into Studio you the other
person you are really you know in love
with and helping
um it'll be two against one I'll come in
you can ask me all of these riveting
questions but that's not the point the
point is they looked up and they were
like oh my God this little black chick
is about to win and we can't have that
right because what was done to me was
not and this is something for the
Republican party right to uh for for the
voters uh to pay attention to that I was
not dragged with these horrible lies
right calling me a black lives matter
um um um
empathize yeah supporter that I'm a part
of black lives matter they would they
would uh get a picture of me and they
will flash a picture of me after saying
black lives matter or flash a picture of
me after saying black rioters right you
know of playing those really stupid
games and it wasn't the left who was
doing this to me it was my own party
which just shocked the world I mean I
know you know politics is dirty but
that's a whole nother level and what in
and you know I I I'm a conservative and
I think I don't think it was racist
necessarily although racism and elitism
feels a whole lot alike in today's
economy of things no one's going you
know no one came to my house and told me
to walk out and try to you know Lynch me
or anything like that that's real racism
right but this was really ugly it was
really nasty
um it wasn't just Politics as Usual
um and so but the Republican Party
I know they want us to be all about the
party and I recognize that it's such a
dichotomy for me because there's no way
on God's green earth would I ever vote
for a Democrat right and we live in a
two-party system so you're either voting
for one or the other and yet I you know
it was my values that brought me to the
Republican party with my values that got
me involved in these political races and
I do not believe I have to abdicate my
values in order to support the party I
think it's our business to beat the
party into alignment and right now we
have not just a cabal among ESG
corporate board members are cabal among
Democrats but we have it also within the
Republican party and if I could just say
one more thing
let me just throw this out here as well
I don't believe I believe I have a
tremendous amount of Hope by what I saw
in my race and my race in those last
five days we were about to win and I saw
over 330 000 pennsylvanians almost a
third of pennsylvanians came out and
voted for me right and they did so in
defiance of millions of dollars of lies
from people like you know Rick Grinnell
uh Greg Kelly uh Sean Hannity they
defied them they also defied all of the
Trump influencers who came out and said
don't vote for her they defied Donald
Trump himself and they still came out
and voted for me that gives me a
tremendous amount of Hope right that
people are not willing to just check
their brains at the door and just do as
they're told people are waking up
something what you said a little bit
earlier people are being red peeled and
they're recognizing something has gone
fundamentally wrong with how our nation
is being governed and we want different
the problem is that lost by roughly Five
Points and it was as a direct result I
believe of what you know uh you know
people who say they are conservative
people who say they are a part of our
party did to shove someone else down our
throat and so now we got to live with
that decision but I still have a
tremendous amount of Hope by what I see
how my race turned out and that people
just they refuse to be denied a better
option Hannity may as well have endorsed
fetterman because Dr Oz is unrelatable
and unlikable and that gives fetterman a
huge Advantage look I've seen the videos
that fetterman puts out he's got health
issues he's got something you know
really really wrong with his neck I hope
he's okay I don't know what that is he
was always wearing it was the weirdest
thing he's in suits and he's wearing a
scarf and it's because he's got
something he's got something seriously
wrong I mean the man had a stroke but
you look at the videos and and Dr Oz
pronounces the name of a store wrong
that was this was a big big I don't know
what did he say was it Wegmans or
something Wegmans uh yeah I don't
remember what happened and then he was
like my wife's trying to make crew today
and it's just like who is is he trying
to pull Suburban white upper class photo
or something and then fetterman comes
out and he really tries to play up to
the to the Philadelphia you know working
class Democrat you know a good old boy
or whatever these are these are the guys
that showed up when the When Auntie was
trying to tear down the Christopher
Columbus statue this is a predominantly
Democrat City yeah that's what fetterman
is going for when Henry came out and he
tanked your campaign pain and then helps
prop up Oz He was basically saying I
hope Letterman wins listen fetterman is
horrid I mean horrible right I mean he
was horrible before the stroke now he's
horrible
with health issues a horrible person who
had a stroke right that's who he is
essentially I mean I mean just I mean
from the you know from his physical
appearance before the stroke his
physical appearance after the stroke
um you know his ideologies his thing you
know I mean the man chased down a black
man with a shotgun
what was that story what happened
exactly so like the black man was just
outside trying to get some exercise and
just just jogging he claimed he heard
some gunshots so he grabbed a shotgun
went outside and there was a black guy
jogging and he chase after him yeah
crazy just happened to see a random
black man running right and then you
know he drops his son off runs in the
house gets his his shotgun gets in his
truck barrels down on this black man and
holds him there with the shotgun up to
his chest until the police came right
and said oh you know I was thinking
about I don't know one of the school
shootings and you know and I thought I
heard a gunshot dude is is Saturday
morning nine o'clock in the morning
school's not in right and it was with
fireworks it was a very different sound
I I have absolutely no idea but this is
a horrible individual and he would make
a horrible Senator
um you know and my hope is that people
will wake up and yet at the same time I
have to say you know if we keep holding
our nose voting for the lesser of two
evils I mean you have to begin to ask
yourself as conservatives what are we
actually conserving we now have red flag
laws we now have 87 000 new IRS agents
who may or may not be armed who the IRS
has told to now start tracking
transactions of 200 or greater we now
have open borders I mean it's just a
Litany of things
um that we would that we were like you
know we don't want so at some point
maybe November 9th we'll be ready to
have a conversation about what we need
to do to make sure that our own uh
Elites within the Republican party don't
tank the next conservative who's about
to win solely because they want to keep
control yeah this is how they get you
with the voting for the lesser of two
evils this has been the Ponzi scheme run
on the American people for very long and
then of course we have Dr Oz who was an
early promoter of trans children all the
way back in 2010 and and just back to
the question because I'm really curious
why do you think Donald Trump did this
was it because Sean Hannity was in his
ear or was there something else
happening behind the scenes
yeah no comment I think I gotta go back
home guys I think I think Hannity for
whatever reason wants fetterman to win I
think I mean I love that moment where
Tucker Carlson is doing the handoff with
John Hannity and he's talking about I
think he was talking about Amazon and
Amazon screwing over the American people
and then as he's handing it off Hannity
goes to private Corporation if they want
to provide a good and people pay for it
they're allowed to do it and Tucker just
does the Tucker face like what what yeah
like that was like a clear split between
the populist new modern Republican base
which Tucker is is a big proponent of
and a big part of and then the old
corporatist neocon Republican
establishment of Hannity Hannity talks
with Trump probably said you got to go
with us that fetterman wins I don't
think he literally said that he probably
just lied to Trump and Trump was like us
huh okay I'll go with us
I don't think Trump wants fetterman to
win I don't think Trump does I think
handy does
um I think that we have a party outside
you know I'm not talking about Oz I'm
not talking about the race I'm just
saying in general it's something that I
said um the entire time when I was on
the campaign trailer that we have a um
you know um and
the Republican Elites uh they are not as
concerned about winning as you and I may
be concerned about it they are more
concerned about control if the GOP was
interested in winning they would be
knocking down my door trying to get
someone like me who was able to move the
needle not just within Republican
conservatives which I have a strong
grasp on but the ability to walk into
any community and and share our story
and move people into our category we
need that kind of energy and enthusiasm
desperately within the Republican party
and if the Republican GOP the elite the
machine within that was interested in
winning they would have my little brown
face all over the place but they don't
because it's not about winning it's
about let's make sure we control the
narrative and we only have our people
and our faces right uh out there saying
what we want them to say and that is
again my heart grieve because I I don't
believe it's hyperbole we are about to
lose our country and I know most
Americans don't think that we can that
that can happen but I believe we're on
the precipice thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive live library to check out so
again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there